the jurgen experience the best thing is
to get into the state we could just be
doug stanhope and i go doug stan hope
you're on and just push you understand
and to get me into that state i have to
know incorrect what time i should not be
shit-faced like that was last night no
no this this don't take 50 milligrams
come on take 175 don't take 15
milligrams and then have joe rogan go
show starts now let's do mushrooms let's
do mushrooms let's do it oh i'm scared
i'm scared me too that's the point come
on how long has it been
yesterday i did do uh for me
i'm doing them all the time all right
small amounts
exactly uh i don't want to even say her
name but yeah carmen morales what yeah
she came out she was her name don't say
her name she's a comic don't
listen to me you don't want to say her
name don't say her name
let's call her
she would want her name to be said no no
she wasn't dealing she's giving you
drugs yeah
don't you've given me drugs
don't tell these [ __ ] people can you
black out the joe rogan experience and
just say the extent of stan hope a
legend
when uh i the first time he and i uh did
dmt i was worried i lost him i was
really genuinely well oh my goodness
we're gone oh my god
you had
thing where i was i was like do i lift
him up so that he doesn't swallow his
[ __ ] tongue i was like oh my god if i
kill doug if the man show dies because i
give doug
it was dying by the way that we knew we
were writing the last monologues ever
and that's what [ __ ] me up
we've told this story every time i'm
sure on your podcast but we were at your
house writing
we know this is the last of the
monologues and they're [ __ ]
just pap dredged [ __ ] awful
uh what's up it wasn't that bad but by
the end wasn't that when we know it's
[ __ ] over and we're beaten yeah well
there was some last time you want to
smoke dmt
my first time like all right this sucks
and we're just getting through this and
then you you want to smoke dmt and then
i go [ __ ] into alternate realities
and then i come out of it 10 minutes
later saying i remember i i came out of
it just saying oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my goodness because i've
just learned the [ __ ]
you know what else you said you said
you've already seen this
you said that to me oh you've already
seen this
you've already i swear the picture of
[ __ ] bill hicks on your wall winked
at me and when i said that to you the
one with him and then the lighting the
american flag with the cigarette yeah
what you know lighting the uh cigarette
with the american flag but i came out of
it and i looked and i swear bill hicks
[ __ ] winked at me when i said that to
you you went uh [ __ ] looked at me
like cliche
[Laughter]
i swear that happened i'm not even that
big a bill hicks fan you were just you
were just insecure because you had like
experienced death and you came back when
we would when i would go outside to
smoke cigarettes from the writer's room
on the lot after that for a week i
couldn't make direct eye contact with
the giant dumpster-sized electrical
generator because i thought i could make
it blow up with my mind the wiring in my
head
was so
i've never done it since
people try to drop that off at the merch
booth we should do it ever again we
should do it tonight [ __ ] no yeah come
on yeah when i'm when i'm about okay
when i'm gonna quit smoking cigarettes
you're better now because of that day
i don't know yeah you are you know why
because you know that that's possible
you didn't know that was possible but
it's hard to break up okay i'm gonna
write a bit
about this that now i know is dog [ __ ]
and means nothing
because i've been through that
experience where you go this is all so
[ __ ] life is so silly but you still
have to make a living but doug just
express that
you don't have i've been doing that but
i know you have but don't worry about
that it doesn't have to be dog [ __ ] and
silly it's you you don't think about
that think about you
think about if you were like some 24
year old guy working a [ __ ]
newspaper distributor office you had a
[ __ ] job and you're allowed to
listen to podcasts and you listen to you
talk about your experience don't worry
about like your own
[ __ ] weirdness in handling it worry
about what it is what it is is like you
died and came back
like you really felt like you died and
came back when you came back i didn't
feel like i died you said tell me like
let me you said to me
hear say your honor this is what you
said you said life
eats life he said life just eats life
life eats life life eats life this is
what you said when you were coming out
you were like life just eats life life
just he's like it just keeps going it
keeps going life eats life life eats
life i'm just trying to hang on life
eats life life eats life it's like you
already been there you've already been
here you've already been here
ultimately like you took you took me to
this place you already been there i'll
never forget that because i thought you
were gonna die i was like god it
nobody's ever died from this [ __ ] i'm
like if doug's the first guy to die i'm
like he's like maybe i like overestimate
the rpms that his [ __ ] engine can
handle and redlined
but you you got through it that was the
thing you kept saying life eats life
life is life life it's life but the the
the
dichotomy of having to go from that
supernatural experience
in 10 minutes and then go back
to oh wait now we really have to try it
finishing up these dumb monologues yeah
but that's okay too that's okay too
because that's a unique challenge that's
like there's some weird thing we're
doing like what are we doing
you